Marvel showed off another full trailer
for Avengers endgame here are all the
details you may have missed the trailer
starts similar to the first trailer with
Tony Stark in space sending a message to
Pepper Potts the love of his life who
didn't want him to go to space in
infinity war we get a bit more of the
message he leaves for pepper where he
reminisces about the past and how he
became Iron Man by fighting his way out
of that cave back in 2008 iron man he's
on the Bennet are the ship that belonged
to the guardians of the galaxy which he
probably used to escape Thanos's
homeworld of Titan it's important that
Tony is reminiscing because in the first
half of this new trailer we see a lot of
flashbacks from the movies that led up
to endgame next we see scenes from
Captain America the First Avenger where
Steve Rogers is a little man before he
becomes Captain America that's where we
get what might be the biggest clue from
the trailer
that's the voice of Peggy Carter Capps
love interest from the First Avenger who
passed away in civil war the quote is
actually from Winter Soldier when Kat
visits an old Peggy in the hospital the
quote continues
as soon as this quote ends we see cap
helping to carry Peggy's casket at her
funeral which occurred in civil war is
the start over heart at ease to the
rumors of time travel with caps staying
behind in 1945 to grow old with Peggy or
isn't misdirection the same way the
Russo brothers showed the Hulk fighting
in Wakanda in the infinity war trailer
just to hide the fact that it was really
Bruce Banner in a Hulkbuster suit we
also get a shot of Hawkeye showing his
daughter how to shoot a bow in the
comics Hawkeye becomes a mentor to keep
Bishop who also takes up the Hawkeye
moniker is Marvel setting Hawkeye's
daughter up to be the Cape Bishop of the
MCU we also get a bit more of the scene
where Black Widow appears to go find
Hawkeye now holding a sword and looking
like his bronan alter-ego from the
comics it seems certain now that Hawkeye
will return with Black Widow in the
first trailer when we saw Hawkeye we
heard Captain America say we lost
friends we lost family which may suggest
that Hawkeye family was lost in a fan of
snap seeing his daughter in this trailer
makes that seem even more likely next we
hear Thor say I saw all these people die
Thor's vision of destruction from age of
Ultron has come true another important
note worth mentioning is black widows
hair it's gotten a lot longer and is
read again as opposed to when it was
blonde and infinity war which means at
least a few months have passed since
everyone disappeared next we see Scott
laying aka ant man who looks overwhelmed
by all the posters of people missing he
was in the quantum realm when the snap
happened so he might still be trying to
figure out what happened is this one he
decides to make the trip to the Avengers
compound we saw in the first teaser this
is Scott way we met a few years ago then
we get an important exchange Black Widow
tells Captain America
a small chance we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
then cap says we will
followed by Hawkeye Black Widow and
eventually Ironman repeating him saying
whatever takes could this really mean
they're attempting something as risky as
time travel even with a small chance of
success
sounds like the Avengers finally have
something to avenge we see an aircraft
approaching the river it's hard to tell
if it's a Quinn jet which the Avengers
used to travel or the Benatar
could it be Tony Stark and nebula making
their way back to earth towards the end
of the trailer we see a bunch of the
Avengers walking in new spacesuits we
see Captain America ant-man
nebula Hawkeye war machine Iron Man and
Black Widow so it seems certain that
nebula and Iron Man will meet up with
the team we get this awesome shot where
the weapon loving Rocket Raccoon is
really enjoying riding into battle on
war machine we don't know what Hawkeye's
haircut means maybe he wanted to be more
like Carol Danvers finally yes
Captain Marvel has made it back to earth
looks like she'll fit right in on the
team the large visible when the camera
pulls back we see Black Widow with the
short blonde hair she had an infinity
war but given the long red hair she has
throughout other parts of the trailer
does this take place months earlier than
the rest of the trailer do Thor and
Captain Marvel have their own missions
separate from the rest of the team they
aren't shown in the spacesuit walk so it
is possible we'll find out how it goes
at the end of April when endgame hits
theaters what did you think of the
trailer did we miss anything let us know
in the comments